-Welcome back to "Late Night".
We're here with Billy Porter.
You went on a 25 city tour?
-Yes.
-And how did you feel?
What was your experience
traveling the country?
-It was wonderful
to be back as myself.
You know, I've become famous
playing characters,
so it was nice
to be back as myself.
It was also very nice --
You know, Brandi Carlile
talks about this.
She travels all over the world,
and the people that she meets,
you know, she -- she realizes
that America is not as divided
as our news cycles
might make us think.
And that was so --
it was so special
to just go out and touch people
and reach people and hug people
and give the world
a big bear hug.
And just, like, you know,
I just wanted to bring joy
and hope again and peace again
and, you know, make people
talk to each other again.
You know, we've been through
this collective trauma
where we've, you know,
where we've separated,
and it's time to sort of
come back together.
And so, the -- the concert
really did that for me.
It was 25 cities
and five weeks,
and people came,
which was fabulous.
And, you know,
audiences from age 9 to 90,
all races and colors and creeds
and sexualities and genders,
it was -- it was magical.
It was amazing, and I can't wait
to go back out.
-That's exciting.
So, that's a lot of shows
in a very short period of time.
Did your energy ever flag,
or did you just ride
that enthusiasm of the audience?
-Well, I've been doing
eight shows a week
for over 30 years.
That's my wheelhouse.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You know,
everybody was concerned.
I'm like,
"That's not the problem."
-[ Laughs ]
-The problem ain't me
doing the show, the problem
is my budget ain't big enough.
[ Laughter ]
Don't worry about the show.
I got that part.
-[ Laughing ]
-[ Laughs ]
-You mentioned writing
all the songs in your album.
What is your creative process?
Are you collaborative?
Do you do it fully on your own?
-No, no, no, no, no, no.
I can't do it on my own.
I come from the theater.
It's a very collaborative
art form.
You know, I write scripts,
I write plays,
I do some of that by myself.
I also have a writing partner
for that.
But with the music,
I don't play any instruments.
So I need a crew.
And this time, it was great
because unlike
my first experience,
these people were actually
listening to me.
-Right.
-And listening to what it was
that I want to do --
wanted to do.
It was Justin Tranter, the late,
great Andrea Martin,
Emily K. and Jade Thirlwall
over in London,
and, you know, we would just
sit, and we would talk,
and then, we would just
build and layer.
I'm a -- I'm an ideas guy,
I'm a lyric guy,
I'm a top line melody guy.
And then, all the other stuff,
you know, falls into place.
It was really great.
I had such a great time.
And these artisans really
helped me with my vision,
and helped me realize
this really specific
and individual vision.
-Were you there
for the whole process?
Was there ever a time
where you, like, went home
at the end of the night,
and when you came back,
they'd done work on it
and it felt like,
you know, the -- the elves
who do the cobbling?
-Yes.
You know, the production part.
-Yeah.
-That happens in the production.
-And that's so amazing.
-Yes.
-I mean, the few times I --
It's not for music,
but it's, you know,
you see an edit of something,
you see graphics
that have been added,
and it is so stunning to see
what these people can do.
-It's gorgeous. And you know,
I can't do everything...
by myself.
-But you come pretty close.
You come pretty close.
-I come close,
but I can't do everything
by myself.
And I-I don't know.
I like the collaboration process
so much.
I really, really do.
You know, people are
in the room with you.
I find writing sometimes
to be isolating --
-Yeah.
-...when you're alone
and by yourself, and, you know.
So I'm a people person,
and I love to be with my people.
-Well, we're very --
We love to have you with us.
And we thank you so much
for making the time for us.
Congratulations on the album.
-"Black Mona Lisa",
November 17th.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with Darren Aronofsky.